ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la maquilleuse quoique et qui vous a dit
quelque chose comme ça tu sais pas qui
me dit écoute à l'occasion d'un simple
dans le cinéma tu feras des seconds
rôles je peux faire des premiers héros
non j'ai pas dit non mais circulez pas
mal dans le cinéma
vous êtes le genre de ben jawad comment
commencer un petit peu circulé mais je
peux jouer à la lumière allez vous êtes
vous êtes l'un des rares humoristes
quand vous avez dit y toucher un petit
pas l'imitation
vous avez humilié didier deschamps la
perfection et plus récemment karine
lemarchand d'aller nous faire les
chroniqueurs on doit trouver de clis
avalisé à ce que je peux faire un gros
bisou à ludovic berrien bien sûr une
rare hier la prison qui nous regardent
wael ludovic bravoure et à fait
exceptionnelle et brad wall
c'est parti tu es parti après tout
parès commence doucement tout grâce à la
petite reconnu c'est qu'on ne sait plus
comment ce troc je fais des retournés de
tête est tout à fait des retournés de
tête mais est ce que jean avec les
perruques ou sur les perruques a avec 1
avec a fait comme c'est facile avec les
plus grands vins non même avec les
paires utilise à peu près tous les
[Rires]
favoris niveau scemama me sens bien ici
dans les détails
ça suffit ça c'est ce qui se passe et
gilou et qui avec ses vaches le temps
plus difficiles celui-là arrive à
celui-là il est subtile ok attend faut
que je m'assieds celui-là géraldine
géraldine série l'1 vous offert un livre
n'est le prendre voilà c'est celui ci
voudrait voilà feuilletée oui nous
sommes et bien vous lisez des trucs non
pas l'une a rien dedans n'y a rien c'est
une autobiographie de la carrière de de
leurs maux
[Musique]
annexe i like violer la mède
je me remets la coica le jeu nantais
mois fait le jeu du thé allez vas-y
parce que tu as les comédiens son
attelage fait passer l'âge adulte et
allez je te salue que [ __ ] c'est à
vous je vous explique les séries il y as
d'été qui sont ici iliad était
dégueulasse que l'ancien t'arrête pas de
voir une subtilité
alors à chaque fois il ya deux il ya
deux tasses de thé y en a une qui est
très bonne une québec il ya des odeurs
ouais c'est ça à l'olympia genre depuis
des mecs tout tremper leurs pieds dedans
et donc s'il va falloir prendre le bon
bout mais on doit on doit jouer le mec
tous mais le mec détend kif
voilà je t attends faux excuse moi tiens
ce que j'aime penser un peu truck series
et autres imite assure eric roy gamin
problèmes toi
vas-y autres imitations ouais
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
alors j'adore
[Musique]